[Music]
no one did more to mainstream
libertarian ideas about peace love and
understanding over the past half century
than pj o'rourke who has died at the age
of 74. and like frank sinatra elvis
presley and sid vicious pj did it his
way by taking a blowtorch to the sacred
cows of both the left and right the
democrats are the party that says
government will make you smarter taller
richer and remove the crabgrass on your
lawn he warned the republicans are the
party that says government doesn't work
and then they get elected and prove it
writing in popular outlets such as
national lampoon rolling stone in the
atlantic and appearing on shows like
npr's wait wait don't tell me o'rourke
distilled the insights of milton
friedman ein rand and friedrich hayek
with far more oomph than they could ever
manage giving money and power to the
government is like giving whiskey and
car keys to teenage boys wrote o'rourke
when buying and selling are controlled
by legislation the first things to be
bought and sold are legislators
libertarianism isn't political he
insisted it's anti-political really it
wants to take things out of the
political arena like his journalistic
inspirations tom wolf and hunter s
thompson o'rourke was no armchair
curmudgeon or ivory tower philosopher
king at his very best in books like all
the trouble in the world and holidays in
hell he engaged the world directly and
often at great personal risk traveling
to war zones and disaster areas in more
than 40 countries including urban and
rural hellholes in the united states i
have
always belonged to the pessimistic wing
of the libertarian uh um attitude this
is probably because i spent 20 years as
a foreign correspondent largely covering
wars and insurrections and
social upheavals and disturbances of all
sorts of ugly kinds we have a rational
side
thank god but it isn't the only side in
our multifaceted and sometimes pretty
ugly little personalities
even as he despaired over a presidential
contest between joe biden and donald
trump he was never dissuaded from his
faith in individuals yearning to be free
whether they live in chicago or china at
the core of libertarianism as an
attitude and as a way of thinking about
politics he said is the idea that people
are assets his elegiac 2014 book the
baby boom how it got that way and it
wasn't my fault and i'll never do it
again writes his epitaph far from being
either a screed against his own
generation which is what he expected it
to be when he started writing or an
attack on millennials it was instead of
funny and thoughtful meditation on how
we've arrived at a kindler gentler
country that somehow manages to price
individualism and community innovation
and tradition when asked whether the
fights between the greatest generation
boomers and millennials had left the
country weirder and better off he told
reason i think so certainly more
tolerant in fact tolerance isn't even a
good word anymore because tolerance
means well i'll put up with you if i
have to you know
um is more enthusiastic about people's
differences you know
applauding them embracing them as it
were um and that's that's good if that's
true it's in no small part due to the
contribution o'rourke offered up
first by making us laugh then by making
us think and finally by making us want
to go out into the world he traveled
with such passion
[Music]